efectivamente quizás es que finalmente
se cumplen los que los expertos en la
constitución de la república y en tema
de leyes le sugirieron a la presidenta
xiomara castró de que fuese una juez de
la judicatura la que tomará el juramento
y es que en este caso si los integrantes
del poder legislativo están en conflicto
como lo que sucede en este momento le
corresponde en segunda instancia al
presidente de la corte suprema de
justicia pero en este caso la corte
suprema de justicia
pertenece o fue nombrada por el gobierno
saliente de juan orlando hernández
por lo tanto castro no iba a permitir
que ellos le tomaran el juramento así
que se acudió a la tercera opción que es
precisamente lo que acabamos de ver en
este momento y justo cuando tomaba su
juramento xiomara castro hacía su
ingreso la vicepresidenta de los eeuu
tan mala hans y en bienes como la comida
es muy importante y acá lo trascendente
son los resultados de estas reuniones
bilaterales que sostendrán la presidenta
e inmediatamente después de que
concluyan así el estadio nacional de
tegucigalpa los actos de protocolo
estamos a punto de escuchar el discurso
de la presidenta acción mara castro que
está acompañada aquí en este escenario
deportivo de fútbol por más de 35.000
personas
además se han venido representantes de
las etnias de honduras y algo que fue
muy significativo y que lo exigió la
presidenta xiomara castró es que
estuviera el pueblo lenca de donde era
originaria la líder ambientalista
asesinada bertha cáceres así que ha sido
muy significativo este acto también han
estado familiares de muchas personas que
fueron asesinadas durante el golpe a su
esposo manuel zelaya rosales y en estas
últimas luchas cuando xiomara castro que
también perteneció a una colisión en las
elecciones anteriores junto al que ahora
es su aliado principal salvador las
ranas perdieron las elecciones y después
en boca de ellos dijeron que fueron
robadas precisamente por el presidente
saliente juan orlando hernández aquí se
mantiene una gran expectativa en las
afueras del estadio nacional de
tegucigalpa después de que termine este
acto principal el pueblo ha sido
limitado a una plaza central a sostener
una fiesta donde después habrá
diferentes artistas que
estarán ahí en contacto con el pueblo y
simultáneamente pues la presidenta
tendrá una reunión con los principales
invitados especiales que han llegado en
las últimas horas a tegucigalpa para
presenciar este arte son solemnes
qué ha sucedido aquí en honduras y es
que por primera vez una mujer asume la
presidencia de la república
kenia estamos viendo en directo imágenes
está su esposo manuel zelaya imponiendo
de la banda presidencial y no está el
presidente saliente juan orlando
hernández a qué se debe esto
que se conocía con muchísima
anticipación
hace aproximadamente fue el mismo ahora
es presidente juan orlando hernández
quien públicamente se había disculpado y
había dicho que no estaría en este acto
de juramentación igual que sorprende
porque se tenía previsto que fuese uno
de los presidentes del poder legislativo
que está presente en el estadio nacional
muy redondo el que impusiera la banda
presidencial pero bueno en este caso es
estás haciendo
la confirmación que es su esposo quien
lo está haciendo es importante señalar
que ya hemos conocido algunos miembros
del gabinete de la presidenta de omar
castro
bueno se ha confirmado que incluso uno
de sus hijos también será ministro es
decir que ella está con la gente más
cercana
en la gente que la ha acompañado y por
supuesto algunas de las personalidades
de la vida política del país además que
hay muchos profesionales en el campo de
la medicina que sostuvieron estas luchas
que candentes en las calles por el tema
de la pandemia y que en este caso ha
acompañado a la presidenta durante su
campaña han sido electo de manera masiva
por el pueblo y personal de confianza
del que se está haciendo acompañar la
presidenta xiomara castro viene a llamar
la atención también que no sólo fue
xiomara castró la que tomó juramento
sino una serie de personajes que tienen
la figura de una especie de
vicepresidentes a que quienes son estas
figuras
en efecto son precisamente salvador
narran a el presidente del partido
salvador de honduras y doris gutiérrez
que es la representante del partido
innovación y unidad pinu que son los
entes políticos con los que se alió el
partido libertad y refundación y que
ganaron las elecciones ellos tienen en
la figura este designado presidencial
que como bien tú lo dices es como que
sean dos vicepresidentes los que
acompañan en este caso a la presidenta
de la república cabe señalar que según
los expertos y los analistas políticos
es gracias a la figura de estas dos
personalidades que en este caso son los
designados presidenciales en el caso de
salvador nasralá con una trayectoria e
impecable que nunca ha sido señalado en
casos de corrupción y en el caso de
doris gutiérrez que es es una diputada
del congreso nacional que siempre hay
hasta estaba identificada con las
grandes luchas polares y por supuesto en
contra de lo que ella ha llamado el
régimen de juan orlando hernández